[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité les Restos
du Coeur sont en proie des difficultés
financières l'association s'est résignée
à réduire son nombre de bénéficiaires
c'est environ 150 000 personnes
concernées selon Patrice douret
président de l'association la raison la
hausse du nombre de demandeurs et des
coûts de fonctionnement dû à l'inflation
face à cela le gouvernement promet 15
millions d'euros d'aide supplémentaires
dans les Yvelines les Restos du Coeur
opèrent dans 27 centres d'activités
la chaleur fait son grand retour cette
semaine en Île-de-France et températures
atteindront jusqu'à 33 degrés dans
certains départements l'agence régionale
de santé conseille de s'hydrater
régulièrement et de rester au frais
ce week-end c'était la 13ème édition
d'électrique Park un festival de musique
électro après un week-end au rythme bien
élevé sur l'île des Impressionnistes à
Chatou le bilan est un succès sur ces
deux jours 80 artistes se sont succédés
sur cinq scènes avec des DJ
internationaux comme Robin Schulz Ghost
Rider ou encore le duo Infected Mushroom
pour le plus grand plaisir de plus de
30000 festivaliers
[Musique]